Un miracle se produit lorsque le premier train du Kyushu Shinkansen Sakura se croise
Cette rumeur a tout déclenché
Hey, je suis désolé, enveloppe de paiement mensuel d'octobre.
Avril
Po-chan, qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
C'est bon, je veux rester avec Mila, et je veux suivre Fukuoka.
moi
Et ma mère me manque en faisant le tour de Sijan
Ceux qui verront l'art atterrir en le mangeant pour la première fois verront leurs souhaits se réaliser.
Vraiment
[musique]
tu veux ouvrir d'occasion
Est-ce que Brianna viendra
Dois-je l'acheter Andose Un tel changement ouais
[musique]
Regarde ton père pour les chiffres qui se réalisent
Même ma famille devra être bleue
Tout d'abord, le système qui se transforme en centre commercial et chante
Mahayana, garde-le papa n'est pas le tonnerre
Tu comprendras tôt ou tard
[musique]
Les pensées pures des enfants
Vous souhaitez faire plaisir aux adultes qui vous entourent petit à petit ?
Panier parce que je ne veux pas te voir
Je vous aime
Parce que je pensais qu'on pourrait revivre ensemble à Osaka pour ma famille
Oui
[musique]
[applaudissements]
miracle
les miracles qui pourraient arriver